kim kardashian is responding to kanye
west's claims that he received footage
of an alleged second sex tape of her and
her ex-boyfriend ray j but a wrap for
the keeping up with the kardashians star
tells e.t there was nothing sexual in
the footage adding that quote kim
remains firm in her belief that there is
no new second tape that exists after 20
years she truly wishes to move on from
this chapter with focus instead on the
positive things she continues to do as a
mother entrepreneur and advocate for
justice reform you think you do
something in private and then the whole
world sees something and you're not
prepared for it all this comes after
calling a sit-down interview for
hollywood unlocked with jason lee where
the rapper started to discuss how when
going through a separation people will
do things to intentionally hurt you
bringing up kim's relationship with pete
davidson how you to bring me to snl
and kiss the dude you dating right in
front of me and everybody's like oh
that's that's cool yay then went on to
allege that during the night of kim's
snl hosting debut he personally
retrieved a laptop with more footage of
his estranged wife with rayjay
aside from the sex tape that was leaked
in 2007 shortly before kim became a
household name thanks to ease keeping up
with the kardashians
after i went and went and got the laptop
from ray j myself that night
right and then got on red i met this man
at the airport then got on the red eye
came back delivered it to her at 8 am in
the morning and then i gave it to her
and she cried when she saw her you know
why she cried when she's not seen a
laptop because it represents how much
she's been used
it represents how much people didn't
love her and they just saw her as a
commodity in the past kim has been open
about how kanye stood by her side even
though he was advised not to date her
due to her 2007 sex tape
but when it comes to how kim plans on
addressing her past with her four kids
whom she shares with kanye obviously
that's nothing that you want to be seen
here's what she revealed on watch what
happens live with andy cohen in 2019.
what will you tell them about that
um i don't know yet i mean i have an
idea and i think i'm just gonna be super
honest and real with them and
i mean that's all you can really be